all right let's get into uh the market
itself uh you recently described it as a
trendless chop explain what that means
uh in terms of what's happening right
now
yeah so this first section is actually
written by uh our equity analyst blake
davis i think he always does a great job
but i think he's generally just talking
about broader markets um you know not
really seeing any trend i'll do that
like moving averages which is price
structure in general um just kind of
just seeing like you know as you said
trendless trendless chop um i think
that's that's also pretty true for for
bitcoin as well but definitely with
uh all kind of the macro uncertainty and
you know we've got everything going on
with like russia and ukraine
i think that's kind of translating into
price action and dri-fi but uh yeah
that's personally that's definitely not
my area expertise so you'd have to ask
blake exactly what he meant there and do
you think that that is uh
the same thing for bitcoin as like the
broader market right now
in in what sense you're saying like the
trendlessness yeah yeah the trendless
chop
um yeah i think
i think you know we've been in a
downtrend for three months
and um you know as we get further into
this i'll highlight a couple levels that
i think we kind of need to
get back above just you know
definitively say that we've kind of
broken out of this downtrend
um you know we've we've seen some you
know promising um you know behavior over
the last like two weeks but i still
think we need to get back above 47k
that's kind of my uh line in the stand
from like a high timeframe perspective i
think there's a lot of uh confluence
there i'll be that with on chain as well
as price structure and if we can reclaim
that i think you know we've regained uh
momentum so like
i think i think there's in this market
there's like value buyers and there's
momentum buyers and this is a mental
framework that i stole from abby feldman
at block tower but i really like it
and i think
value is kind of in the low 30s and
momentum is getting back above that 47k
area
and so you know for people that are you
know kind of just looking to get in the
market on like high time frame momentum
i think that's kind of the area that you
should be watching
makes sense um i saw that you were
tweeting about and you included in the
newsletter uh hash rate and just kind of
the explosive recovery uh of hashrate uh
talk to me about why is that so telling
to
you yeah i think you know it's it's
really incredible this is one of the i
think biggest accomplishments of the
bitcoin network uh maybe i mean in
recent history but maybe in all of its
history reasoning is because you had one
of the you know largest global
superpowers being china banning bitcoin
mining we saw a massive exodus of hash
rate coming off the network as you can
see in the chart uh between may and july
during that time
i think this was actually you know a
fundamentally bullish event in the
moment because now all of a sudden you
have all this hash that's moving out of
china and that was one of the the big
you know uh
fuds if you will that you would hear
from people oh all the mining you know
hash power is concentrated in china
so now that you know that argument is
gone and with that as well over the last
few months we've seen a complete
recovery of that hash back on coming
back online
and what this basically means is that
all these machines have been migrated
across the world in a completely
decentralized way both the physical and
human capital around the world and
re-plugged in
and just you know in several months
we've seen that not only come back to
where it was prior to the prior to the
drop but actually we've seen this
continue to ramp up over the last few
weeks we've seen a really aggressive
move up in hash
and here at blackberry we continue to be
very bullish on on hash we think over
the next year we'll continue to see this
this this trend as more just entities in
general uh continue to be interested in
getting involved with bitcoin mining
um you know i think yeah again it's just
it just kind of goes to show you know
the resiliency of the bitcoin network
and currently the network's more secure
than ever as as hash continues to grind
out yeah talk to me about the uh kind of
derivatives market obviously there's
been a lot of uh activity there as we go
sideways that looks like it's kind of
lining up with a lot of the price
movements
yeah so um on screen i think we have the
the bitcoin price chart with the
perpetual basis indicator below so first
we could just like talk about price
briefly uh so again i think kind of the
low 30s or a value area for btc i think
47k is that area that btc needs to
reclaim to kind of establish momentum
especially from a high time frame
perspective
um these are some of just the four kind
of major price levels that i think we've
got for bitcoin on a daily level
um i think we're currently sitting at
an important kind of pivot level if we
go back and look at where 41 to i'm
sorry 40 to 41k
uh we've seen a lot of kind of reaction
from price from that throughout the
throughout the last year so that
basically defined the whole summer range
we bounced off that at the end of
september
uh bounced off that in january before
finally breaking through
and as well you know recently we've
we've seen some reaction of the last day
or two with this price area
i think if bitcoin can flip this 39 to
40 area then you're probably looking at
continuation back up to 47 at a minimum
if we get back below that well then once
below then 40k becomes expensive so i
think if you start closing below 40 you
probably see btc retraced back to these
local lows but for the next day or so
i'm just kind of watching to see this
reaction in this area
i think you know if it can't hold then
that's quite bullish probably so yeah
you know move back up to 40 47k
if we start closing below probably see a
retracement back to those local lows so
you know with this stuff you know it's
always probabilities it's always
speaking in if then statements right no
one knows exactly what's going to happen
we just identify the setups and we set
up you know probabilistic statements
based on that information and so with
that being said again i think if we can
hold this area see continuation to 47k
if we start closing below the 40k area i
think we probably see a retracement back
to those local lows hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time